ich glaube es geht schon ich hab's
geschafft ich hab's geschafft durch ein
freund und willkommen zurück bei der
opfer zusammen mit pg 5 adam & eve als
marco hallo mam bus war lang
den wollen wir nicht
aber ich wollte auch sagen weil wir
nicht irgendwann uns hier ein checkpoint
setzen
peter ich mal zu mir nehme kommt schon
an gedeckelt da er okay gut das schaffen
wir auch ohne checkpoints an
was ist da und was erwartet uns dann
versagen clara ich kann auch den hebel
umlegen dem platz kein problem
ich bin längst rechts vorbei und er
schafft das auch wenn ich im lager
gelandet
das ist echt mies dass die falsche seite
das ist echt böse das ein ganz ganz
unten das wasserbecken ist nach an den
lagerbecken dann vorbei alter das
geschäft noch fast gar nicht dass doch
unmöglich
ich würde sagen ich nehm doch mein bett
mit uns meint checkpoint da hinten
das kann nicht sein
ich liege im bett und fall aus der map
update auch einzeln gestellt so zwei
hingestellt
ich habe voll cool dass man den chat
jetzt so die deckkraft runterschrauben
kann das echt hilfreich ich bin ganz eng
dran zu sein
ich war ganz eng daran dass das ist das
kann man nicht reich an fakten ich hab
fast in diamond aus der kiste geholt
habe ich auch schaffen wenn man
irgendwie durch die lava durchgeht oder
so bei mir einen solarfabriken nicht
nachgelassen
stimmt wann ist da im boden bei der lava
drin
man kann auch durch die ersten 3 durch
aber ich versuche mal eben durch das
letzte
nein aber das klappt ganz sein dass es
da so verschieden verschiedenen
verschiedene regel gibt quasi ich glaube
auch als man immer die kätzchen wechseln
muss ja irgendwie so das zitat total
schwer
ich versuche gar selber sonnenweg das
klappt nein das dass die ersten drei
geklappt ersten drei plätze bei ich
nehme das wenn man runter springt unten
rechts da klappen die ersten drei ich
habe es danach gar nicht zu wechseln
ganz nah ran darf einspringen 29 war das
knapp welches bisher angesprochen unten
rechts ist zu recht
ich glaube ich hab's geschafft ich hab's
geschafft
ich hab's geschafft ich bin unten
gewechselt ich habe wenn ihr davor steht
sag ich mal wenn ihr da gerade rein
läuft wenn ich sage mal wenn ihr vor den
schaltern steht und dann rein springt
das links 3 also links links links und
dann rechts rechts
das ist aber total schwer mit ansage
jetzt hat ich habe aber schon mal den
diamond und eine menge trifft bochum
liegen von den ganzen mist space
gedrückthalten glaube ich das wäre ganz
cool ich werde immer schneller wird
lichtgeschwindigkeit durch den hass
super mega lecks mit einem herzen
ich hab auch dinge es hier ging es gegen
alle möglichen sachen diamond star
geschafft ok super
hallo ich komme nicht aus meiner haut
nicht na gut dann fliege ich halt hoch
kommt auch nicht ganz nah das packt
manchmal ein bisschen rum
und da fliegen dort jetzt auch nicht so
lange kommt hinter mir her meine kinder
oder machen wir in kentucky fried
chicken fest denn oben richtig gebraten
jetzt habe ich voll bock auf seiner
heimat schicken wings schnell was
anderes denken mit ihren check point
setzten sich in die toilette denke ich
glaube braucht die seismischen nun auf
swissness ich hab's geschafft ich habe
auch geschafft aber hier sind nur zwei
boote nicht durch mit dem hier irgendwo
der diamond so viel sei gesagt nur dass
ein minister nicht in der toilette
hier könnt ihr hier seht ihr die kiste
chance nimmt am klo dasteht so gut habe
ich meinen diamanten auch immer
versteckt kronjuwelen auch gott jetzt
mal wiederkommen bitte funktionieren von
neuen game holt mächtig ein
auch durch links überholt ja ich bin
gleich da
halleluja hallo schwebe über euch moment
so habe ich gebratene cookies ich muss
mich bei gamern lauf kann kein gutes
essen und müssen auf den netz landen
nicht das ist das andere
ich glaube das andere ich bin jetzt auch
da wo dinge wo marco ist du bist uns
andere gesprochen haben machst du kannst
hier oben herunter springen
step by step
zuerst mal aufs blaue was meinten der
mit vier ja aber dann erst hier aufs
blaue oder wie ich gehe einfach mal das
recht darunter du kommst dort nie wieder
raus das sind ja denn von spinnweben
ach ihr angst haben dass eigentlich von
verplant das zimmer der kaktus auch das
thema ist so schräg glaubt ja genau wo
sie hätten jetzt in gesprungen woche das
blaue ballons egal wenn ich hierhin
stellst und hoch schaut dann sieht
wieder richtig aus dass wir neben dir
hört man jetzt auf das rote ich finde es
echt interessant diese idee ist ja ja
ich bin im wasser drin und danach auf
gott oh gott jetzt bin ich ein zweiter
und da müssen wir hin
hier sind die cookies folge der kuki
spur er kennt den cookies linie sowie
cookies marco macor wenn ich gestorben
ich bin hier fast unten oder ist ein
diamond promised land ein land da
horchen fest ich bin runter gefragt hast
du denn damit nicht eingepackt sein
es ist ja sooo geil aus mit dem
waschbecken wir uns von hier unten müsst
ihr euch das mal anschauen
ja du ich hänge gerade im netz welchem
letzten neuanfang
was soll uns jetzt erst einmal geschafft
habe winter pro keiner schafft das jetzt
aber auch jetzt musst du ins wasser da
ich auch noch nicht nur das waschbecken
das ist gleich unter euch jetzt und dann
bin ich jetzt hier in so eine rein und
dann noch mal und das voll auf das
waschbecken aus wo dann kannst du ein
zweiter in seine rolle sieht echt krass
aus brille unter die einfach das ist
echt geil aber der pakt ist auch schon
wieder vorbei
das heißt ich würde sagen den nächsten
part mit diesem kompletten badezimmer
gibt es dann bei gaming pc fünf morgen